guys here's the deal entrepreneurship
you're going to have highs are going to
have lows I promise but as long as you
get yourself back up nothing can hold
you back and stop you I was dead broke
I was bankrupt in order to make ends
meet I was driving a beer cart at a
country club success it's up to you
don't let anybody dictate what is going
to make you feel fulfilled and what
makes you feel happy I was pitching the
Alfa M style system but a three hundred
dollars a pop for a fashioned formula
customers just invite and alter did you
hello believe nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the major problems of the world
so to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn from men's
lifestyle expert Aaron Marino and my
take on its top ten rules of success
rule number three is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys like the best and as always
guys as you're watching if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
put quotes around it so other people can
be inspired and when you write it down
it's much more likely to stick for
yourself as well
enjoy
my name is Aaron Marino
I am a men's lifestyle expert and
grooming guru and if you would have told
me ten years ago that I would find so
much happiness joy and fulfillment
making videos on YouTube I would have
punched you in the face my journey to
finding this success and happiness and
voice unfortunately wasn't a straight
line there are a lot of bumps and turns
along the way and they ultimately
started a broke kid from Philadelphia
whose parents got divorced and I was
raised with an abusive stepfather I lost
my ability to stand up for myself and so
I kept everything inside I had all this
anger hostility and resentment my mom
gave me a Fitness membership to a gym
and when I went I found my home it was
the first time that I felt like I
belonged from the age of 13 I knew
exactly what I wanted to do with the
rest of my life I was going to own a
fitness center I go to West Virginia
University I graduate I met a guy we
opened a few nutrition stores and
ultimately that didn't work out because
he was selling drugs out of the back and
I realized that prison wasn't a place
that I would would be flourished and so
I left there and I met a woman that I
helped lose a hundred pounds and she
came to me and said hey I want to start
a fitness center and this for me was my
dream and it was tough well I didn't
make much money it didn't matter because
I was happy I was doing something I love
we took some loans and got some some
investors there was a big issue with
with one of our investors and my
business partner and it ultimately ended
up in lots of legal fights and battles
we had to end up shutting down this
business I was dead
broke I was bankrupt in order to make
ends meet I was driving a beer cart at a
country club and I'm sitting there with
peers rushing down my face because I
don't know where to go I was at the
lowest point that I ever have been
giving up was never an option
the problem was that I didn't know what
success looked like anymore but what I
do have is a dreaming and desire to help
people at the time there really wasn't
anything any resources out there for
regular guys to get some solid basic
advice on how to look good and feel
great I decided that I was going to help
men feel better and amazing about
themselves so I have a video camera I
was the least tech-savvy person you'd
ever meet but I picked it up and I
decided that I was going to try and film
a video and put it on YouTube everything
changed for me I found that new vision I
found that new passion all the sudden I
had a voice I had an audience and I was
doing something that made me feel
incredible because I realized I was
doing something to help other people and
with YouTube I was able to help millions
of men around the world feel better
about themselves that's what I was put
on this earth to do and I feel like true
confidence comes from helping other
people all along I was searching for
success I thought success is going to
mean a fitness center a chain of
nutrition stores and I put myself aside
and just focused on the act of helping
other people feel better about
themselves
everything in my life got better at the
core of it it's just helping others are
you a risk taker successful people are
but not just random haphazard like I'm
driving drunk without my seatbelt type
of risk I'm talking about calculated
risks you weigh the options you weigh
the potential outcome both good and bad
and you make the best decision possible
but guys I'm here to tell you that you
are never altima ting to be successful
unless you're willing to put yourself
out there having the ability or the
willingness to potentially fail is an
absolute benefit and sometimes these
calculated risks even though you thought
about them sometimes they just don't
work
yeah and know what successful people do
that's alright I learned something I
know what not to do next time and you
make another calculated risk guys
nothing great was ever achieved because
it was easy so we talked all about the
importance of knowing who you are having
a secure sense of self is a key
component to the confidence equation who
are you what are you capable of I've
been asking myself this a lot lately and
it seems like the more I ask the more I
realize that over the course of my life
I have been limiting myself
due to some arbitrary set of
restrictions or limitations that I put
on myself years ago and I know that I'm
not alone why this is a question that I
need you to start asking yourself why do
we have these limitations what are our
own personal limitations gentlemen it is
time to stop living like the elephant
all right now bear with me while I
explain this elephant analogy okay have
you ever been to the circus have you
ever seen those big massive elephants
they're held to the ground by this
little rope and a tiny little snake are
these elephants not strong enough is
this like kryptonite rope that these
elephants are attached to oh of course
not these elephants are badass they
could one tug of the tough they could be
out of there and Delaware buy dinner
what they don't why because they've been
conditioned from a young age when the
little baby elephants joined the circus
I like to think of them as joining poor
elephants anyway I digress
when these elephants are little they get
to the circus and they put a big strong
rope on them and they stake them to the
ground now at the time these little
elephants like what the hell are you
doing and they start jumping and dancing
and trying to get loose to begin because
those little elephants and this is a
strong rope and a big strong stake so
the elephant after a while gets it in
his head hey I can't get loose and so
they stopped trying because they know
that they can't get free well the
elephant grows up the elephant gets to
be a teenager and his friend stronger
he's been working out then the elephant
is an adult by this time he is massive
he is strong he is capable of pulling
out that stake and getting lost but he
doesn't because of his mindset because
he
he remembers when he was little he
learned that he couldn't and so he
doesn't and much like the elephant the
only thing holding us back the only
limitations that we have are these set
of rules are these things that we have
created for ourselves the standards for
ourselves that we created years ago a
lot of time it's 5 10 30 years ago and
just like the elephant we remained
chained it's time to analyze identify
and give yourself the permission to
break the chains gentlemen
we are so incredibly powerful the only
thing that is holding you back holding
me back in our life and from achieving
whatever we want to achieve are these
preconceived notions that we can but
there's somebody in your life that told
you that you couldn't that dissuaded you
when it wind it when you're a little kid
right when you're a little kid what do
you want to be when you grow up and
astronaut everybody's like a fireman I
want to be a police officer I want to be
a ballerina whatever don't look at me
like that
it was possible at the time but then
what happens through your years as you
grow people are telling you know people
tell you you can all right it is
incredibly rare to have and be
surrounded by a nurturing environment
where the people in your life tell you
you can do it you can do anything you
can achieve you can strive you can go
for the gold but so often all right it's
these negative people that stick out you
can't do that
you're not smart enough you're not fast
enough you don't have the ability and we
hear this and in the back of our head we
adopt it and we set these rules for
ourselves these self-imposed limitations
gentlemen it's time to break the change
their change change thing there again
it's not you change Fred Donna where do
you have limitations in your life what
is holding you back
you are absolutely strong enough smart
enough fast enough confident enough
gentlemen it's time to start living with
passion with purpose okay I realize that
there are things that our life we all
have them I have them we all struggle
with that negative thought in our head
all right these preconceived notions
these limitation that's in I believe in
you you need to start believing in
yourself it absolutely kills me and
breaks my heart whenever I see you guys
and you're not living up to your
potential because of your limitations
and these limitations are so arbitrary
there's absolutely nothing to them no
foundation don't let other people set
your expectations of yourself guys you
can do anything you want break the
chains and stop living like an elephant
one of the most eye-opening pieces of
advice that I've ever received was when
I heard that we teach people how to
treat us this idea was groundbreaking to
me and I started analyzing all of the
different relationships that I had and I
realized absolutely I was teaching
people that it was okay to treat me a
certain way because I would never stand
up for myself all right there was a guy
that I opened some nutrition stores with
and I'd end up working more than I
should because I could never say no or I
want to make as much money he'd make
more because well I never would stand up
for myself and say no I deserve it too
another reason that we as creatures have
such a tough time standing up for
ourselves is that we're afraid of what
will happen if we actually do this was
definitely the case in my situation when
I was growing up I was so petrified of
having to move change schools change
friends that's what I loved and it was
easier for me just to take it at home as
opposed to having to potentially move
and that's what the risk I felt was if I
would stand up and say eh that's not
okay or if I would argue so in my early
20s I realized that I had a problem my
problem was the inability to basically
stand up for myself
and it was really starting to bother me
and so I decided to go see a therapist
and it was one of the best decisions I
ever made but unfortunately one of the
things that I had to basically realize
and accept for myself was that if I
wasn't comfortable standing up for
myself in certain situations with
certain people I needed to get out of
those environments because it was never
going to get better the anxiety that I
felt even thinking about standing up for
myself was way too much me it wasn't
worth trying to work it out with this
guy that I was in business with it was
easier just to say deuces I'm out and
leave because it that's the choice I
made
I don't know if it was right or wrong I
feel good about it but a lot of times it
is you've got to make a decision
sometimes you're going to lose friends
sometimes you're going to lose careers
you could potentially lose a significant
other or spouse if you finally stand up
for yourself but the alternative is you
being eaten alive inside and that's just
something I wasn't willing to deal with
and when I left I said okay if I'm going
to be out of here I need to change I
need to make sure that I start asserting
myself and taking care of myself and so
I started doing it when I felt that I
was being treated poorly I'd say
something now one of the things that
happened is I would get crazy
butterflies I would almost pass out I
would get so much adrenaline and gets so
nervous and but it's like anything else
if you practice the more you practice
the more you stand up for yourself
you're going to find the easier it's
going to get the other bonus and upside
to standing up for yourself is that
these toxic people and relationships
seem to start going away because they
are comfortable putting you down and if
you're going to stand up they're going
to be like I don't want it now I'm going
to find somebody else who's a pushover
one of the things that we do that
totally prevents us from moving forward
and excelling in our lives careers
relationships and everything is
surrounding ourselves with people that
we really probably shouldn't be
associating with you are alright your
success is going to be the average of
the five people that you spend the most
time with during the day know this is
tough alright because you think about
right now take an inventory of your five
closest friends or the five people
during the day that you spend the most
time with are they losers are you not
exactly happy with where you are right
now well guess what they're not going to
raise you up to the top okay they're not
going to make you look better they're
going to bring you down successful
people surround themselves with
successful people meet personally you
know I want to be friends with I want to
be friends with people that are smarter
better that under that are more
successful I want people that are like
here in my mind alright I want to be
here I want to be the low man on the
totem pole
why because I'm going to
dirty up that freaking ladder like a
like a squirrel chase of a nut
alright guys surround yourself with
successful people if you're currently
hanging out with people that don't have
Drive don't have motivation that are
kind of losers I lovable losers but
losers nonetheless reevaluate your
current circle and adjust if this means
you've got to cut some ties or maybe not
hang out quite so much it's okay if you
need to seek out other people to bring
them into your life into your circle I
suggest you do that as well success as
defined by Webster is achieving wealth
respect or fame and I personally think
this definition sucks and is exactly the
reason why so many of us feel like
failures because we haven't lived up to
some arbitrary set of success standards
and so today I thought we'd take a
little bit of time and talk about
success what it looks like to me and
what it looks like to you because
ultimately you are the only one who can
define what success looks like to you
and I think it might be time to
reevaluate we are taught from a young
age to win all right winning was success
it was the goal winning in sports
winning in your career winning at life
the pursuit of life liberty power and a
ton of money this is what I thought that
success was supposed to look like well
every time I analyze myself and my
accomplishments I ended up feeling like
a failure because I didn't have power I
didn't have a lot of money and I didn't
have Fame and this is what I thought it
meant to be successful because in my
mind I taught everything everything in
magazines everything on TV if you're
successful you got tons of cash and you
got tons of power until one day I
realized God care about those things
right I don't want to be powerful it's
not my goal
I don't need tons of money as long as I
have enough to be comfortable I'm cool
money wasn't my motivator so why would I
time my feelings of success to it this
realisation rocked my world and totally
changed my perception of everything
and truly it felt like a thousand-pound
success weight was lifted off of my
shoulders I thought amazing I was free
so once I realized that this wasn't what
success looked like to me now I got to
figure it out what does success look
like what did I need to do what did I
need to accomplish in order to feel
fulfilled and happy and I figured it out
and this is what success looks like to
me my professional success meant that I
was doing something that I loved that I
was able to touch other people's lives
and make a difference personally I was
successful if I had relationships with
those people that I loved that were deep
and meaningful nothing was left off the
table you let people know how you feel
you communicate and reciprocate the love
financial success just meant that I had
enough money that I didn't need to worry
about money not saying like hey I can go
and buy whatever I want because I don't
really have very expensive taste meaning
that if I live modestly
I have to worry about making it paycheck
to paycheck emotional success to me
meant that I was in touch with my
feelings my emotions and that I was good
with the person I saw looking back at me
in the mirror all right it was all about
having a solid character and confidence
if I can achieve those four things and
not only achieve them but maintain them
let me tell you something to me that is
success every day when I wake up that is
what I focus on I focus on being
successful and what it means to me it
doesn't mean that I have a ton of cash
it doesn't mean that I have power or
fame or worldly riches now but to some
people that's what success looks like
just not to me
so I wanted to share my story tell you
sort of the journey that I took in order
to identify and realize what success
actually meant to me and I would
encourage you to take the time to figure
it out for yourself all right the first
thing you need to do and the first step
is throwing out all those preconceived
notions all the things that you've been
bombarded with from your parents from
society from social media from TV from
movies from everywhere throw it out it
doesn't matter you get the start blank
clean slate and figure out what success
looks like to you maybe success
you live it on a beach right being able
to get up every morning and paint the
ocean I don't know maybe success for you
is having a family having little kids
run home view and just being a dad right
success it's up to you
don't let anybody dictate what is going
to make you feel fulfilled and what
makes you feel happy guys do it now
figure it out write it down and then
every single morning you get up and
focus focus on what it's going to take
to make you feel whole and feel
successful this my friends is a gift and
once you figure it out you are going to
be amazed and how good it feels and how
successful you become the first place
you need to start when trying to become
a better man is attitude it's all about
changing your mindset and perspective
alright right now you're feeling a
little bit crap you're like I'm not good
enough I've got low self-esteem
here's the deal you need to focus on all
of the amazing positive attributes that
you possess alright change your mindset
you will change your attitude because I
tell you you can have all the nicest
clothes in the world all the money all
the cars everything if you've got a
crappy attitude none of it matters your
mindset your attitude about yourself
about ourselves that is the hardest
thing to change but the thing that once
you get it everything else seems to fall
in place confidence this is what alpha M
was all about and what I would come to
realize was the reason that I was put on
this earth to help guys feel better
about themselves it's it's hard for me
to talk about I had this passion and
this desire to help you burns so deeply
inside of me and I feel it through every
ounce of my body and soul confidence
this is the key to feeling great about
yourself without it you will absolutely
never know your true potential or how
amazingly powerful you could possibly be
so when I realized that it was this
confidence and I wanted to try and
facilitate and other people I told some
people about it and they're like you
can't teach confidence either you have
it or you
don't and these are people that I did
respect and so it sort of got to me a
little bit and I thought to myself hey
maybe you can't teach or maybe you can't
learn confidence they told me just stick
to style don't talk about this other
stuff but I decided that I wanted to
keep talking about the other stuff talk
about things that I thought were
important to develop character because I
really did feel like hey maybe it's
going to help at least one person and
then something remarkable happened I got
an email it's from a guy watch my videos
his name was Brian and he told me that
through watching my videos he actually
felt better about himself and that he
was more confident and this was like one
of like really I it was the best day of
my life and something else strange
happened I got another one and another
one and another one gentleman I realized
that I was right you absolutely can
learn to be confident validation
confidence is a skill it can be learned
but now came the tricky part I needed to
figure out a structure and the system
how to actually walk somebody through
the steps to become more confident it's
taken me two years to complete but I
finally did it gentleman I am incredibly
proud and pleased to announce that the
Alpha M confidence course is complete
the Alpha M confidence course is a step
by step system to help you unlock the
five phases of self-confidence bays one
is learning an exploration you've got to
be able to take a hard look at yourself
ask yourself two tough questions in
order to drill down to figure out who
you are as a person and what has led you
to where you are now as a person until
you understand who you are you can never
move forward phase two is developing
your physical and external confidence
fitness style grooming diet all of these
topics are discussed in detailed and
outlined in Phase two think of it as
confidence from the outside your work on
the outside it transcends to the inside
and then phase three is all about acting
and communicating
confidently phase four is living
competently and then we're wrapping it
up with phase 5 which is adoption but
here's the interesting thing about
confidence and any skill for that matter
is that you need to continually nurture
and do the things that you did in order
to get to that level of confidence so if
you get to be confident feeling good
about yourself right if you stop doing
all those other things that led you to
here guess what the insecurity is going
to creep in confidence is not a thing
it's not a destination it's a journey
that you're going to be on your entire
life
that's it guys I got trouble after the
gym I go home I eat I shower and I sit
on the couch and work a little bit more
until about ten o'clock then I go to bed
sleep for about seven hours and do it
all over again
I know that from the outside looking in
it might seem like I'm always working
but I don't feel like that I feel
honestly like I'm the luckiest guy in
the world this point in my life and my
career I still love what I do and every
single day I get up and I am so excited
to take on the day and to create content
and to work and create businesses and
and it's just incredible first up is an
entrepreneur from season four returning
to the tank with a new opportunity for
the Sharks
[Music]
hello sharks my name is Aaron Marino and
I'm here today seeking a $100,000
investment for 10% equity stake in my
new company Pete and Pedro so if I look
familiar to you it's because I've been
here before but last time I was pitching
the Alpha M style system yeah but a $300
a pop for a fashion formula customers
just didn't fight and either did you
but you gave me something more valuable
a new direction and life-changing advice
you see I knew you were right I needed a
lower price point product something that
every guy needed and used about a month
after I was on Shark Tank now I am down
on my hair when inspiration struck and
Pete and Pedro was born a new line of
super awesome and hair styling products
being Pedro equals bueno hair or selling
direct to the consumer which means a
higher quality product at a great price
guys buy it they try it they love it and
sign up for the bueno hair Club where we
automatically ship them their favorite
Pete and Pedro product every four six or
eight weeks bull sharks I'm back this
time with a product that men need and
love and I'm not walking out of here
again without a deal so who's ready to
partner with me and share the hair
gentlemen what's happening guys thank
you so much for watching this video but
really I think I owe the biggest thanks
to Joshua religio sorry for butchering
her name brother but he is the one who
actually recommended or asked Evan to do
this video on me and I can't tell you
how incredibly humbled and and honored I
am to be on Evan your channel because
you are doing some incredible things for
incredible guys guys here's the deal
entrepreneurship you're going to have
highs are going to have lows I promise
but as long as you get yourself back up
nothing can hold you back and stop you
before I go I would just like to leave
you with this something that I learned
along the way and that is that success
doesn't always look like what you expect
or what you hope it will keep your eyes
open realize that sometimes the universe
has a different direction so make sure
that you listen both with your eyes and
ears and that was super cheesy
anyway guys thank you so much keep
rocking and rolling and move forward
gentlemen you got this
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Joshua remedial
asked me to because there's a famous
entrepreneur that you I'm going to
profile next check out the link in the
description and go and cast your vote I
also want to give a quick chatter -
Joshua where'd Regas Joshua thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word doing the collaboration
with me and tweeting out that fun
picture as well I really appreciate the
support man and I'm glad you enjoyed the
read so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
true story what ad my fitness centers it
got pretty bad towards the end I
expanded too fast there are a bunch of
internal issues remember I was saying
choose your partner's wisely it got so
bad financially for us that I was having
to take money off her credit cards in
order to pay my employees and so in
order to make ends meet I had to take a
second job on weekends working as a beer
cart girl on a golf course our private
member's on the golf course and if there
was there was a moment when there were
lots of moments doing that but it was
winter it was about it was February and
in Atlanta it does get cold especially
at 6:30 in the morning on a Sunday there
was frost it was about 23 degrees and
there's no heat in the in the cart and
so I'm sitting there waiting for golfers
to come around there's no shelter I'm
just in this cart shivering my butt off
and it was that critical moment in my
life when I realized that my god I will
do anything it takes in order to be
successful the walls my empire that I
had planned on building and creating was
crumbling right before my eyes and there
I am sitting in a beer cart a thirty
like two year old dude serving beer too
drunk golfers swallow your pride you're
going to do things know that you're
going to do it and times could get tough
you give up too easily when the tough
gets going you do something else because
the thought of actually having to
persevere and work through things is too
much for you to handle
alright if you are somebody who gives up
way too easy you get any slight hint of
resistance in any capacity you're like
whatever I don't want that anyway and
you're on to the next thing if this is
you you are never going to ultimately
achieve your goals and the desired
success level that you're striving for
now I know that I personally have
experienced quite a bit of
disappointment in my life and I'm
assuming that you have as well and guess
what we're going to continue to be
disappointed throughout our lives at
least we should be because if you're not
that means that you're really not trying
now how you handle yourself post
disappointment this is critical to your
emotional and mental well-being
hmmm pain hurting right it's part of the
growing process but I'll tell you
something life has a funny way of
closing doors in order to keep you
moving in the right direction
alright so often in our society and as
people we run from pain we do everything
we can to protect ourselves and to
shield ourselves from feeling
uncomfortable that feeling of pain and
this is the reason why so many people
abuse drugs alcohol casual sex we do
this to not feel the pain but I'm saying
stop running stop trying to mask it all
right when you feel pain disappointment
it's okay
don't try and cover it up what you
should do is actually embrace it I know
it's easy it's easy for me sitting here
saying oh embrace the pain you're
feeling like crap don't worry about it
feel it feel it I get it right that's
not it's kind of a long shot but what
I'm saying is that the pain is normal
its natural it's a part of the growth
process learn from it once you do you
accept it you embrace it
learn from it put it in its place you're
going to be able to move forward
stronger faster smarter if you're not
struggling and getting disappointed from
time to time this probably means that
you're not really pushing your limits
too far all right it's okay
embrace it don't get discouraged and
stay focused